il y a quelques années à l'adolescence
angèle a été placé au foyer de jardy
malgré sa nouvelle vie elle n'a rien
oublié et des méthodes brutales de la
directrice qui selon elle n'aurait pas
hésité a drogué les enfants pour avoir
la paix c'était le soir à table
deezer et du catr d'anne-laure leur
compte la mettez la dans ce conseil ils
font toucher après et dont c'était du
tercio le version est un antipsychotique
puissant habituellement prescrit pour
traiter les délires paranoïaques et si
elles incluent refuser ou 7 et des
claques à des grandes chaque derrière le
crâne quoi charmant à elle n'y allait
pas de main morte
ce premier extrait alors se fait
évidemment dédié à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance en audience c'est pas terrible
du tout 2,3 millions téléspectateurs ces
trois cent mille 2 mois que la
précédente émission et surtout quatrième
des audiences étaient cinq en effet 4
millions 1
donc voilà un score plutôt décevant pour
ce numéro qui pourtant vous l'avez dit
rien et alors bouleversant et la
l'extrait devant maintenant vous allez
voir si l'on se rend compte que certains
ados et en parler les fixes se
prostituent c'est dramatique
regardez le cas de cette petite semble
particulièrement préoccupant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais satan a entendu parler ou à vue je
suis personne ici n'a l'air d'ignorer la
dérive de cette jeune fille est selon
ses salariés elle ne serait pas la seule
à se prostituer côté le bart avec 101
souple qu'elle revienne et du gîte et
l'argent et qu'elles sont en vente
et puis il se vend des dégâts pour
d'argent je sais ce qu'est ce que l'état
va réagir parce qu'effectivement la ja
il ya une vraie urgence
kevin et surtout le gouvernement a réagi
juste après la diffusion c'est adrien
taquet qu'elle secrétaire d'état chargé
de la protection de l'enfance qui s'est
fendu d'un communiqué pour justement
pointé du doigt tout ce qui se passe
dans ces foyers ce qu'il faut quand même
savoir qu'aujourd'hui il ya plus de 350
mille jeunes qui font l'objet d'une
mesure de protection donc c'est un vrai
sujet de société et c'est dommage que le
gourou que le gouvernement agisse
seulement après la fusion avec d un
reportage des pronostics pour ça le
reportage elle était bouleversant mais
je pense qu'il était surtout nécessaire
alors si sur certaines personnes ont du
zap et parce que c'était trop dur ou
presque
les destinations se moque de rêve voilà
mais c'était nécessaire et 2,3 millions
de personnes c'est toujours 2,3 millions
personnes qui ont vu ce qui se passait
chez nous parce que c'est ça ce qui
était dur c'est que c'est chez nous là
on voit pas ce qui se passe à l'étranger
alors évidemment on s'est rendu compte
qu'il fallait plus de moyens pour l'aide
sociale à l'éval enfance mais surtout
qu'il fallait que les départements se
bouge et tant pis si ça doit passer par
la télé c'est un moyen dont on doit
servir clijsters et justement quand à
savoir sur l'utilité de ce genre
d'émission que selena qui vont dire
ouais c'est vachement craspec c'est
voyeuriste et c'est alors que pas du
tout il ya une vraie utilité parce que
le secrétaire d'état dont tu parles
il a été nommé après un reportage sur
proche de celui là donc là sa conviction
il ya un an
et tout de suite derrière l'émission le
gouvernement a nommé c'est d'ailleurs à
bairon que ça n'existait pas avant des
secrétaires d'état chargés de la
protéger quand même qu'on a on a le
sentiment qu'en fait les les ados sont
baladés alors ils font un sang depuis
200 ans et après ils vont famille
d'accueil puis après ça se passe mal et
on les renvoie quelque part c'est aussi
catastrophique
et est ce qu on a vu aussi c'est que
une jeune fille à partir de 18 ans eh
bien allez lâchez elle est tout seul et
ce genre d'émission encore une fois vous
avez raison de les féliciter
ça nous dévoile tous les
dysfonctionnements de ces foyers où ils
ont quitté un environnement où ils
étaient maltraités dans leur propre
famille ils sont censés les protéger et
faire grandir est vraiment encore une
fois ça c'est d'utilité publique mais il
faut faire attention aux dérives bien
sûr